au fil des ans vania aguiar a rencontré
cinq ministres de l'éducation pour leur
parler de l'urgence de reconstruire
l'école ireny lussier cette école
spécialisée est dédié aux jeunes de 12 à
21 ans vivent avec une déficience
intellectuelle et de l'autisme le fils
de mme adama diarra 25 ans aujourd'hui
des dizaines d'élèves comme lui ont
fréquenté un bâtiment désuet un
labyrinthe de couloirs mal adaptés à
leurs particularités sensorielle leçon
la résonance des lieux il ya un élève
qui crient dans une classe au bout du
corridor ça dérange les élèves de la
classe de l'autre bout du corridor c'est
toujours toujours c'est ecofac nos
bâtiments sont vraiment pas adapté ce
projet là avec des larges corridor avec
qui il était il ya été pensé pour nos
élèves on va avoir des locaux adaptés à
nos enfants michèle bernier le père d'un
garçon de 13 ans un élève dit rené
lussier ça demande beaucoup de
persévérance ce qui eût tout les enjeux
politiques
de changement de ministre c'est chez
terra et puis là on arrive à une
finalité harry gabriel ses ports aux
autres qu'on fait ça on est dix ans
beaucoup plus
l'engager pour débloquer les sa et pour
faire avancer des projets aujourd'hui on
n'est pas en train d'élaborer un concept
on inaugure un chantier qui est déjà en
marche l'école tout neuf permettra de
passer de 192 élèves à 250 réunis dans
un lieu qui permettent aux jeunes
d'acquérir les bases d'une certaine
autonomie au quotidien une cuisine le
jardin à l'extérieur tout sort pour les
amener à développer cette chaire étonne
autonomie et les collègues rendent donc
les déplacements les crocs qui montre
des espaces lumineux qui plaisent à
gabriel et harry
très bon accueil très beau cette école
unique au centre de service scolaire de
montréal rayonne bien au-delà du
quartier où elle est située très long
trop long bien sûr comme toutes les
autres projets aussi qui attendent dans
le quartier hochelaga maisonneuve toutes
les autres écoles
au final aujourd'hui c'est une bonne
nouvelle cette fois on peut dire que
l'échéancier est coulé dans le béton les
élèves seront accueillis ici dès
l'automne 20 23 ici anne louise despatie
radio canada montréal